ein kontra zum klimapaket die
regierungspläne reichen nicht sagen die
grünen und wollen über den bundesrat
schärfere maßnahmen durchsetzen
ein plan und eine warnung der iranische
präsident will eine koalition aller
golfstaaten und droht gleichzeitig den
westen
ein sieg nach langer durststrecke
sebastian vettel gewinnt in der formel 1
nacht von singapur sein erstes rennen
seit einem jahr
nachrichten des tages heute mit
christian sievers meine damen und herren
guten abend in allen an diesem sonntag
um 19 uhr der kompakte
nachrichtenüberblick mit sport natürlich
und rudi cerne hallo guten abend das
klimaschutzpaket der bundesregierung
bestimmt nach wie vor die schlagzeilen
es mehren sich zweifel ob es tatsächlich
so umgesetzt wird
die grünen sagen es geht ihnen nicht
weit genug sie fordern einen höheren
preis für co2 und sie kündigen an wie
sie dafür kämpfen wollen nämlich im
bundesrat
denn in der vertretung der bundesländer
gewinnen die grünen immer mehr an macht
bereits jetzt sind sie an neun der 16
landesregierungen beteiligt in
baden-württemberg stellen sie den
ministerpräsidenten
es wären sogar elf wenn sie bald auch in
brandenburg und sachsen mit regieren in
jedem fall könnten die grünen das
klimapaket in der bisherigen form
blockieren frank buchwald das klimapaket
am freitag von der kanzlerin verkündet
seitdem steht es in der kritik besonders
die grünen sind enttäuscht sie wollen
mehr
man hat vier jahren nichts getan jetzt
den großen wurf angekündigt und in
diesem großen wurf steht vor allen
dingen darin dass man weiter vertrag
nämlich auf die nächste regierung ab dem
jahr 2021 und mit diesem paket werden
wir die pariser klimaziele nicht
erfüllen und das ist wirklich bitter und
mehr als enttäuschend die grünen drohen
deshalb das thema paket im bundesrat zu
blockieren
auch die freien demokraten knüpfen ihre
zustimmung an bedingungen
nachgebessert werden muss beim klima
paket die grünen wollen aber eine
ideologisch getriebene
verschlimmbesserung mit noch mehr
verboten subventionen wir brauchen einen
emissionshandel der diesen namen
verdient damit wir wirksam und günstig
klimaschutz organisieren sodass auch
arbeitsplätze erhalten bleiben
auch in der cdu geht das klimapaket
einigen zu weit sachsens
ministerpräsident kretschmann zwar
spricht in der bams von rabiaten
maßnahmen csu-chef söder aber hält
dagegen wir haben jetzt eine chance ein
zeitfenster für wirkliche veränderungen
aber was wichtig ist wir müssen es mit
dem bürger und nicht gegen die bürger
machen
das heißt keine radikalen vorschläge ich
finde das konzept des tals vorliegt das
ist die gute ökologische mitte
die kanzlerin ist am nachmittag nach new
york geflogen angela merkel will ihr
paket beim klimagipfel der un
präsentieren gleich hinterher fliegt in
einer zweiten maschine
verteidigungsministerin kramp
karrenbauer oder als cdu-chefin gibt
sich ak bereits gesprächsbereit beim
klima paket moment beim thema umwelt
wäre bikes e scooter handstaubsauger
oder akkuschrauber kauft soll künftig 50
euro pfand bezahlen
das fordert der bundesverband der
entsorgungsunternehmen
der grund die akkus dieser geräte würden
oft falsch entsorgt und lösten immer
häufiger brände in müllautos und
recyclinganlagen haus durch die
einführung eines pfands systems soll das
verhindert werden
bei der nachricht jetzt werden urlauber
hellhörig den britischen
touristikkonzern thomas cook droht die
pleite
in gesprächen mit investoren soll das
unternehmen deshalb heute um mehr geld
für seine sanierungspläne verhandelt
haben und hofft auf hilfe der britischen
regierung
zum konzern gehören auch die deutschen
marken neckermann und condor
die regierung in london hat angekündigt
gestrandete urlauber im ernstfall sicher
nach hause zu holen
von einem konkurs während derzeit etwa
600.000 urlauber betroffen davon gut die
hälfte aus deutschland am persischen
golf fährt ein brisanter konflikt und
der iran sendet verschiedene signale
jetzt der außenminister spricht von
einem möglichen krieg sein präsident
dagegen bringt bei einer militärparade
sein land als garantiemacht für den
frieden in der region ins spiel
auf der uno-vollversammlung wähle einen
friedensplan vorstellen
der iran sagt er wolle ohne den westen
allein mit einer koalition der
golfstaaten für die sicherheit der
schifffahrt in der straße von hormus
sorgen jörg brase 39 jahre ist es her
seit der iranisch irakischen krieg
begann die gedenkfeiern heute in teheran
nutzt die iranische führung für eine
demonstration militärischer stärke in
seiner rede macht präsident ronny den
verfeindeten nachbarn das angebot einer
gemeinsamen sicherheitsinitiative und
warnt gleichzeitig den westen
wenn die westlichen mächte sicherheit in
unserer
region haben wollen sollten sie sich von
ihr fernhalten ihre anwesenheit hat
immer unheil gebracht je weiter ihr von
mir weg bleibt desto sicherer wird es
hier seien in einer ausstellung
präsentiert das iranische militär die
wrackteile einer us-drohne ende juni im
grenzgebiet abgeschossen auch dies eine
warnung vor allem richtung washington
der druck in den usa wächst ein
vergeltungsschlag durchzuführen und auch
die iranische regierung droht mit einem
umfassenden krieg sollte das land direkt
angegriffen werden die rhetorik wird
immer schärfer und es besteht die gefahr
dass irgendwann der punkt erreicht ist
an dem eine der beiden seiten diese
drohungen wahr machen muss truppenparade
zum gedenktag auch in der straße von
hormus in alldem waffen geklärte
ergreift iran nun die diplomatische
initiative und kündigt einen regionalen
friedensplan 1
in enger zusammenarbeit mit den anderen
nationen der region wollen wir die
sicherheit im persischen golf und in der
straße von hormus wiederherstellen kurz
nach seiner rede brach johanni nach new
york zur un generalversammlung auf am
mittwoch will er dort das
gesprächsangebot an die arabischen
nachbarn vorstellen
zurück nach deutschland günter kunert
war einer der bedeutendsten deutschen
schriftsteller es gestern abend
gestorben
der gebürtige berliner wurde in der
nazizeit als sogenannter halbjude
verunglimpft in der ddr setzte er sich
für den dissidenten wolf biermann 1
siedelte dann in den westen über 1950
erschienen kuhn als erster gedichtband
und erst dieses jahr der roman die
zweite frau den er in der ddr nicht
veröffentlichen konnte günter kunert
wurde 90 jahre alt was ganz anderes
jetzt in münchen haben wieder tausende
menschen am traditionellen trachtenumzug
durch die innenstadt teilgenommen
gruppen aus ganz deutschland und aus
mehreren europäischen ländern
präsentierten den historischen gewändern
brauchtum und handwerkskunst der etwa
sieben kilometer lange zug am zweiten
tag des oktoberfests gehört zu den
größten trachtenumzüge
der welt und ganz in zivil setzt wie
gewohnt sport rudi schon umgezogen und
er kann es doch noch sebastian vettel
ist zurück in der erfolgsspur
nach 392 tagen ohne sieg gewinnt der
viermalige weltmeister das nachtrennen
beim großen preis von singapur
zweiter wird sein teamgefährte stöckler
der damit den erfolg für ferrari perfekt
macht ein großer tag für ferrari ein
großer tag aber vor allem für sebastian
vettel platz eins und zwei für die roten
entscheidend für den ausgang des rennens
ist vettels boxenstrategie der
reifenwechsel eine runde vor jahren
erklärt ermöglicht die führung vor dem
teamkollegen lewis hamilton verpokert
sich kommt zu spät zum boxenstopp und
verliert damit sogar einen platz auf dem
podium
sebastian vettel auf dem weg zu einem
ganz wichtigen sieg forscher erklären
und marxisten
es ist schon so was wie ein comeback des
ferrari stars der war es der erste sieg
nach einem jahr ich hatte jetzt eine
gefühls explosion erwartet warum so
nicht an
na ja also ich glaube in kanada waren
wir nah dran
ich denke hier und da hätten die
wochenenden auch anders ausschauen
können aber ja ich glaube man geht von
wochenende zu wochenende von wochenende
zu wochenende und schaue jetzt nicht so
so weit zurück wie vielleicht die leute
von außen ein befreiungsschlag in
singapur wäre sebastian vettel
abgeschrieben hat wird heute eines
besseren belehrt im ersten sonntagsspiel
der fußball-bundesliga sieht borussia
mönchengladbach gegen fortuna düsseldorf
mit 2 zu 1 ein erfolgserlebnis für die
gladbacher nach der verpatzten europa
league woche und das deutsche team hat
bei der rad-wm in britischen yorkshire
beim erstmalig ausgetragenen
mixed-wettbewerb silber gewonnen
ein erfolg der vor allem dem auftritt
der frauen zu verdanken war
den sieg sicherte sich die niederlande
glückliche gesichter bei der deutschen
team mixed staffel gleich im ersten
wettbewerb die erste silbermedaille
auf platz zwei liegend schicken die
deutschen männer das team der frauen um
lisa brennauer auf die schwer befahrbare
weil nasse straße eine starke zweite
runde bringt deutschland zunächst die
führung diese währte aber nicht lange
die favorisierten niederländer vom
ersten kilometer an zu stark für den
rest der konkurrenz die niederlande
weltmeister und somit erster titelträger
dieser wm
platz drei geht an gastgeber
großbritannien las oder trocken das ist
die große frage
beim wetter dann kann ich die antwort
geben die im nordosten wird es morgen
sonnig sonst überwiegend stark bewölkt
mit kräftigem teils auch langem regen am
nachmittag kommt ganz im westen wieder
die sonne raus das wird nicht wärmer als
14 bis 23 grad also alles dabei nass und
trocken und auch in den nächsten tagen
unbeständig und eher kühl
der hinweis noch auf das heute-journal
21.45 mit marietta slomka und einem
gespräch mit dem
bundesgesundheitsminister der in mexiko
versucht hat pflegekräfte für
deutschland anzuwerben
von uns war es das für den moment morgen
freut sich hier barbara hahlweg auf sie
ich wünsche ihnen allen einen angenehmen
sonntagabend